loan aurait pu participer au programme
baby boom ce petit inimontin d'à peine 1
heure est né à la maternité de poissie
c'est dans ce service que les caméras de
TF1 se sont installé pendant un mois
pour filmer la deuxème saison de Baby
Boom un programme à mi-chemin entre
documentaire et téléréalité les caméras
sont sont fixes en fait elles sont
installées à l'avance dans le service ce
qui fait qu'on a jamais aucun caméraman
en visu donc ça c'est une technique a
priori qui est utiliséoup dans la
téléréalité mais qui permet
essentiellement là dans l'hôpital d'être
complètement seul avec les patients
c'est lingo sagefemme à l'hôpital de
poissie depuis 5 ans elle a participé à
la première saison de Baby Boom suivie
par 2 millions et demi de
téléspectateurs on n'avait jamais vu le
travail de sage-femme de cette façonlà
ça permettait de voir bah que quand même
il y avait pas que l'accouchement il y
avait aussi tout l'encadrement des
couple je trouvais que cette première
saison elle était bien aussi parce
qu'elle permettait de voir ce qui se
passe dans une salle de quand on y a pas
nous professionnels de santé ce qui se
passe entre le père la mère et puis
après lu avec le bébé et que c'était au
plus proche en fait de l'émotion
vraiment ressenti par les gens c'est un
travail sur l'émotion autour de la
naissance l'émotion des parents
l'émotion des professionnels et leur
travail leur travail en équipe 50
caméras dissimulées en salle
d'accouchement aux urgences ou encore en
réanimation des nouveaux nés poursuivre
au plus près l'accouchement de 65 mamans
et le travail d'une dizaine de
sages-femmes on a donc des patientes qui
nous sont
attribuer enfin chacune chacune à ses
patientes et puis on suit le travail en
cours de chaque de chaque dame on fait
les accouchements on récupère les bébés
des césariennes programmés on s'occupe
des enfants qui sont nés des patientes
en fonction des différentes façons
d'accoucher sur les 65 femmes
volontaires seules neuf figureront dans
le programme dont l'intégralité des
épisodes a été visionné par Françoise
damageu très impliqué depuis la première
saison que ce soit dans la première
saison ou dans la deuxème on avait un
droit regard c'estàdire qu'on était deux
personnes moi-même et un des médecins de
l'équipe nous avons visionné l'ensemble
des épisodes nous avions uniquement un
droit de regard sur le niveau
déontologique secret médical Céline elle
n'a pas encore visionné la nouvelle
saison de Baby Boom la sagefemme
découvrira en même temps que les
téléspectateurs le premier épisode sur
TF1 mardi 18 septembre à
23h15